speaking of superstar type talent whoa
joining us now we're doing the hot
change not even a break we're going
straight to it
there he is
campbell welcome back how are you man
what's up big guys doing great
hey what kind of memories do you have
this week you know it's easy to forget
that you were on that cardinals team
the last time the super bowl was in
tampa rookie year arizona cardinals
pittsburgh steelers when you get ready
for the super bowl what's the big memory
that comes back to you from that
experience
oh man
i mean that game was such a fun time the
whole week really leading up to it you
know when i was young i really couldn't
appreciate it the way i would now uh but
i did enjoy it i i uh you know the older
head the old guys on the team made sure
us young guys understood how big of a
moment that was uh but you know the
memory still was always uh was that toe
down was was the centennial homes get
his toed down or not you know and uh you
know obviously uh you know you got to
deal with whatever they called it you
know but part of me is like i still
don't that's always down
i don't know either i'm not sure either
way all right so we're on that
conversation too i mean you hit on the
cardinals yeah you played for bruce
arians too and i mean he looks like he's
a lot of fun just give us you know like
mike said your thoughts what's the first
thing that comes to your mind when you
talk about bruce
yeah i mean he's a great coach you know
players coach you know he's one of those
guys who'll come in and you know you're
gonna work hard but you're gonna have a
good time along the way
and uh you know i mean he's a great eye
for talent and then bringing in you know
uh tom brady i remember uh talking back
this offseason one of my best friends
who's a big football fan
and uh we're talking about where tom
brady was going to land and i'm like man
if he doesn't go to tampa bay i don't
you know i'd be very surprised because
tampa bay and they they have the
coaching they have the players you know
the weapons i mean just you can't really
miss and uh he was he was big on him
going him going to the chargers you know
which i i guess was always a possibility
as well uh but uh it's kind of cool to
see tom brady do what tom brady does and
you know i mean i didn't know he was
going to be in the super bowl i knew
there was always a chance but wow
you went from arizona to jacksonville
then jacksonville to baltimore last
offseason what what was the biggest
difference between playing for the
ravens and playing for the jaguars
i mean uh this year was a
unique year and so it kind of you know
took away some of the the natural uh you
know like i mean the thing i like about
being in baltimore uh i feel like the
locker room uh you got a lot of mix of
old vets and uh and young guys with
talent who love the game of football
and uh you know as you can tell that uh
there's a standard of of just you know
hanging out outside the locker room that
you know i kind of missed to share
because of kovit uh but uh you know i
think the the cool thing about baltimore
is just uh you know the the standard of
excellence that they uh they set forth
and i mean that's not that again
jacksonville was a great place i loved
my time in jacksonville you know uh the
dubai fans showed me all kinds of love
you know i have uh nothing but respect
my time in jacksonville was great you
know uh in both places you know i mean
honestly just play the game of football
anywhere you play it at is a is
definitely a dream come true and uh you
know i'm 100 every time i get to suit up
and play game of football yeah i mean i
know you love the sport i am like i want
to piggyback off that question a little
bit because there does seem to be that
aura in baltimore of this you know this
just tough culture
personalities all of that like
who do you give credit for their ability
to
get guys like that or is it john
harbaugh a great you know motivator
who gets the credit for that culture
there in baltimore
yeah you know it's kind of funny when
you think about like the defense you
know uh and just that toughness uh you
know i mean it really is that's what you
as a player you always try to establish
a standard of excellence and that you
wanted to be passed down and to me like
uh you know in jacksonville that was
what i was trying to do trying to
establish is like all right there's a
you know way we're doing things you know
we're going to go out there and
sacrifice one another you know play with
a stream effort and you kind of see that
mentality and then i get to baltimore
and you like wow you know uh this is
this is on the backs of you know the ray
lewis's you know uh tony saragosa's you
know uh just the guys who you know that
started and paved the way and won that
2000 championship and uh and just
carried on you know you see that it's
kind of you know they they you have a
lot of guys who've been here for a long
time like jimmy smith uh who can who
will play with the greats and tell you
like yo this is the way things are done
around here you know uh and you know
cornell mcphee and so i think it's it's
just a standard of the people that are
here that have been here for a long time
to kind of show you the way of doing
things at baltimore
you guys had some extreme adversity with
the covet outbreak in late november the
losses that kind of knocked the team off
balance but you really turned it around
going into december what was the spark
what was the thing that that really put
the ravens on that track where they just
kept winning and winning and winning
every week
well i mean back against the wall you
know need to win to get in
uh you know i mean we had some success
early then we had just a rough patch and
then we came out you know in that eye
for us to get to the playoffs we got to
win you know we got to win it all and so
there was no there was no tomorrow you
know the playoffs started early and uh
you know we did what we had to do to get
in and you know it just seems like you
know i feel like uh you know uh the
divisional round you know i feel like we
we uh
you know we should have won that game
but we didn't you know they did uh the
buffalo didn't have to win it you know
they made the plays you know we didn't
but you know there's no
uh you know you don't want to make
excuses you know it's one of those
things where even though uh you feel
like we could have been the better you
know we were the better team and we
could have won that ball game you know
we didn't they beat us you know and hats
off to them you know and it just it
gives motivation for next year you know
but as you as we know uh this game you
know it's always changed you know you
don't even know who's gonna be here next
year so you know it's just how it goes
but you know i feel like uh the the
front office they do a really good job
bringing the right people and i'm
confident we're gonna have a team that's
gonna be uh competitive next year and
have a chance to win it all especially
with lamar at the hill yeah no doubt
about it i mean it seems like you guys
got a lot of pieces in place all right i
want to do something like personal to
you because i'm sick of this i've been
fighting this good fight for a long time
like defensive ends like you never get
the credit they deserve there's never
all enough all pros hall of fame
appearances because you don't have sex
i've been a fan i need you to back me in
this in a stat called
f up the play right okay you know what i
mean right because how many times have i
watched you in your career take a double
team on and throw one guy away and now
the running backs got to go somewhere
else and somebody else gets to tackle
but you ruined the play i mean don't you
think something something needs to be
done with guys like you and richard
seymour can you get behind me on this
oh most definitely man i'm hoping
richard seymour gets into the hall of
fame this year you know uh i mean he's a
guy you know who kind of you know he
paid the way for his big guys who just
messed stuff up when we you know we said
we call fsu you know then just mess
stuff up oh fsu i like that i'm gonna
use that
so uh but that's just that's how it goes
i mean to me like i don't care about
actually making a stat i just want to
make sure the play is affected and we
win the ball game we get off the field
so you know i'm always cool with my
linebacker making plays or out you know
the
the guy next to making players you know
it's just about you know set a new line
of scrimmage and and and just quick we
can have it in the backfield yeah we're
going to take care of that we're going
to get you the credit you deserve
i still like f to play up i still like f
to play up better than mess stuff up but
at least mess stuff up
hey uh you caught my attention kalea is
talking about the
the division around game against the
bills because i think some people would
listen to what you said was 17 to 3.
come on it wasn't close but i mean you
watch that game closely
it did feel like you guys
were giving it to buffalo and and you
know what from from the sidelines from
the field what what gave you the sense
that that you guys maybe were the better
team that day or at least potentially in
position to emerge victorious
yeah you know i feel like uh you know
obviously uh the game didn't go the way
we wanted to and you know you look at
17-3 and it's like wow you know that's a
14-point loss that's a blood nfl but you
think about you know just when you look
at the the flow of the game i mean it
was three three at half time and you
know really you know um
you know uh it was a really windy day
and there was you know a lot of things
that can be factors but you know you
know we drove the ball and and didn't
get points you know when we were in
position get points uh three times you
know in that first half and uh on
defense you know um you know uh you know
we we
we really only have given one drive or
they got to the red zone that first half
and then that first drive coming out at
halftime and they drove the field and
scored a touchdown you know and it was
like you know one play here one play
there uh that would have changed the
whole ball game but you know i think you
know two drives that we really uh that
we gave up you know that you know we may
let them make a play we should play here
play there we wish you could have back
uh but it just it seems like
you know uh it's just one of those days
where what could go wrong went wrong you
know uh the ball didn't bounce away you
know it just wasn't your day it wasn't
meant to be yeah yeah i mean you're
right it's 10-3 and you guys had the
ball at the seven yard line going into
score i mean it was a lot closer than
the final score look all right i we've
asked you about you know bruce aryans
the cardinals all that i got to ask you
about you know the other guy playing
this weekend you've had experience
mahomes just give us the the patrick
mahomes experience what what stands out
you know about him when you play against
him
oh yeah man i mean he's uh you know to
me he's just such an incredible talent
you know uh he's he beats you with his
mind as well you know he he understands
all the pre-snap uh you know uh you know
where your witnesses are gonna be you
try to disguise but you know he's real
good at seeing it and his heart count is
ridiculous so it's really hard to
disguise right uh you know and uh and
then uh even when you have the perfect
play drawn up and you beat your man
clean or you come scott free he just
drifts and finds a way to buy time for
his got to get open puts the ball right
on the money i mean uh you know he he's
definitely uh incredible talent and he
has the playmakers around him i love him
that lets him use his talent to the
highest level so you know i i love going
against him because you know i love
competing against the best it brings the
best out of me uh you know but he's
definitely uh you know there's a reason
why he's always in the big game
calais the afc championship game threw
some water on this talk but going into
that game i was hearing from a lot of
people around the nfl as was chris that
maybe the gap between patrick mahomes
and josh allen isn't that great you
played both of them
how big of a gap is there between those
two quarterbacks right now
um i mean
josh allen is a great quarterback i
think he has a great potential he's
young uh but he's talented you know uh
but i think patrick mahomes is
just is uh you know he's it's a there's
a difference there's a there's a gap
there still you know and uh maybe josh
should close it as he continues to
develop and and and grow as a player but
you know patreon homes is a whole
different level i mean he's uh you know
he he's up there you know on tom brady
level in my opinion you know and that's
you know ty brady in this prime even
though tomorrow he's always in his prime
you know he doesn't have a fight yeah
he doesn't lose his prime no we we got
you we got you you're right mahomes is
special that certainly i mean i have no
problem calling the best player in
football right now you i want to ask you
one [ __ ] fun question i think i've asked
you this before but i it doesn't get old
because you're one of the biggest humans
i've ever seen in my life all right at
what age all right well i want to know
like when did you know you were
freakishly bigger than the rest of the
kids
uh well i've been 6-8 since i was 15 you
know
uh but uh
that kind of gives me uh uh so
uh i've always been like intimidating
you know people turn around they see me
they look up and they're like you know
just naturally scared so i've always
kind of tried to be a really nice guy
but it was always in my nature anyway
you know uh you know just want to you
know do to help people and stuff and so
you know it's kind of cool uh just this
last year being the watch payment of the
year you know uh and just you know
represented you know uh you know just
you know from here uh with nationwide
and what the nfl has done with that
award and making it so prestigious you
know i just got to say man uh you know
this has been a incredible ride man and
more motivated than ever to try to do
good things in the community you know
being a big guy i feel like that's like
a natural thing like you know you have
to want to go out there and make your
presence felt every time whatever you're
doing and so just as well as doing stuff
in the community on the football field
and so you know with the walter paytman
the year award man that was a
a great joy of mine this last year
representing the nfl and i got to give a
shout out to nationwide man because
they've done a great job so i'm gonna do
this one time for y'all nationwide
your side yeah i love it i love it done
well done hey
calais the thing that i like most about
the walter payton nfl man of the year
award is that that patch
that only the guys who have won it right
have what did it mean to you to have
that patch on your jersey this year
i mean everything you know uh i feel
like it's the most prestigious award in
sport you know and for me like it
represents you know not only what you do
on the field but what you do off the
field and you know uh uh you think about
the people who wear the patch i mean
this year you only had jj watt larry
fitzgerald drew brees and myself like i
said that's a that's a crazy uh group of
people to be around you know and so um
you know it felt good to be in that you
know exclusive um you know group of
people uh you know but honestly it's
just it motivated me to want to live up
to that standard each and every day
last one for you
if you were 6'8 when you were 15
how old did 15 year old or how tall did
15 year old kaleas campbell think he was
going to be because you must have
thought you were going to be seven five
you know uh it's kind of funny because i
i remember growing and i was like 13. i
was probably like uh six feet already
and uh my dad and uh the doctors were
probably like you know i think you're
gonna stop growing you know don't expect
to be too tall because uh you know i
mean that's what happened with with him
you know so i was thinking maybe six two
six three and then you know i started
hitting my head on doorways and realized
i was a little taller than that
so
here i am six eight but when i got 16 i
didn't i didn't expect to grow anymore
you know so i mean i didn't even realize
i was six eight since after a while
all right well it's great stuff calais
congratulations again on being the
defending walter payton nfl man of the
year and uh congrats on all your success
we look forward to talking to you again
real soon always a pleasure man thanks
for having me see you class
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports